all right so we're gonna go slow what we
have been reporting on night after night
for over a year now is turning into a
scandal bigger than Watergate and here's
why this is all so alarming all the
information we have been telling you
about so far is only a sample of what's
to come it's the tip of the iceberg now
these facts this evidence will rot the
foundation of Washington DC it will make
you question how is it possible this
could ever happen in the United States
of America it's that serious
and it's why we have been pushing so
hard on this program for answers now
meanwhile you have the liberal
mainstream media there's supposed to be
all about truth all about transparency
they have been missing in action they
have turned their backs they are
ignoring the biggest story in their
lifetimes their sole focus has been on
delegitimizing and destroying President
Trump at every single turn now that's
why for over a year
they have been peddling hour after hour
fake news conspiracy theories about
so-called Trump Russia collusion they
have nothing to base it on no evidence
whatsoever and here's what they don't
want you to know about the key officials
that are involved in the scandal let's
start with player number one that of
course would be Hillary Clinton now
remember Donna Brazile in her book she
talked about Hillary rigging the primary
against Bernie Sanders imagine if that
was not old Trump then Clinton tried to
build on that idea she was teaming up
with the DNC they worked through a law
firm they paid over 12 million dollars
for that salacious dossier that was
filled with Russian lies Russian
propaganda why because they wanted to
influence the general election through
lies Clinton also tried to keep this a
secret she went through a law firm
Perkins cuy which then hired Glenn
Simpson infusion GPS and they paid
former British spy
Russian expert Christopher Steele now
according to Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett who's been doing a deep dive
into all of this to crimes may have been
committed in this instance
52 u.s. code three zero one two one
which says it is illegal to make a
payment donation or trade anything of
value with the foreign national in
connection with any kind of election in
America
remember Steel's a former British spy he
was only hire
by fusion GPS once Hillary Clinton
started picking up the tab for the Trump
opposition research not before Gregg
also points out 52 USC 3 0 101 it makes
it a crime to file a false or misleading
campaign report now a watchdog group the
campaign Legal Center they've actually
filed a complaint with the Federal
Election Commission accusing the Clinton
campaign and the DNC of violating
campaign finance laws and for failing to
disclose payments they made for this
dossier all right next up is disgraced
former FBI director James Comey now he
along with corrupt FBI agent remember
Peter struck and other top deputies not
rank-and-file they put the fix-it to
save Hillary Clinton from prosecution
when we know she committed multiple
felonies as it relates to the email
server scandal now call me and his
lackeys they ignored incontrovertible
evidence about Clinton breaking the law
having secret top secret special access
programming classified information
stored in that mom-and-pop shop bathroom
closet remember on the server they also
failed to act after Clinton's team
deleted 33,000 subpoenaed emails then
they acid wash using bleach spit on the
hard drives and then any devices they
had left over they busted those up with
a hammer and by the way the mobile
devices they eventually turned over to
the FBI they were useless it's no SIM
cards in them now despite all of this
call me struck and others they crafted
an exoneration statement months before
ever interviewing Hillary Clinton and 17
other key witnesses in the case by the
way that's not how law enforcement works
and in that exoneration statement when
describing Clinton's mishandling of
classified information call me change
the words the legal standard gross
negligence which is the legal standard
to extreme carelessness and they also
altered a section that said it was
reasonably likely that hostile foreign
actors and adversaries of the United
States had hacked the server and they
completely removed information about
Hillary Clinton emailing President Obama
and which means that Obama knew Hillary
was breaking the law or should have
known now all of this allowed Hillary
Clinton to stay in the
an intial race which obviously they
wanted and then she used the Russian
propaganda dossier why to lie to the
American people
nobody had verified what was in that
dossier not even Glenn Simpson diffusion
GPS now again going back to Gregg
Jarrett according to him if Comey
exonerated Hillary Clinton from
political purposes well that means he
obstructed justice he should have been
seeking the truth and that's only the
start of commis involvement in the
scandal and according to the house Intel
committee and their memo Comey signed
off personally on three FISA
applications to spy on the Trump
campaign and his FBI lied to the FISA
Court about the dossier
being bought and paid for by Hillary
Clinton in the DNC excuse me they did
have a footnote it may have some
political origins but they knew Hillary
and the DNC paid for it
and commis FBI then they also use that
Yahoo News article written by Michael
Isikoff about Carter page they were
corroborating the dossier well here's
the problem
they knew the source for the Yahoo story
was Christopher steel and the FBI never
independently verified the information
nor did fusion GPS because steel was
their only source and by the way from
there it only gets worse according to
the crassly gram memo the bulk let me
repeat the bulk of their application to
the FISA Court the FBI put before a
judge consisted the bulk of it the phony
dossier the Hillary Clinton phony
dossier on March of 2017 Comey told
Congress he didn't bother collaborating
or corroborating the DA dossier because
the FBI thought Christopher steel was
credible really good enough too you
don't have to corroborate these things
and call me also testified under oath
that the same dossier that he used to
get the FISA warrant was quote salacious
and unverified and call me also told
them president-elect the same thing in
January 2016 but it was only just a
couple of months earlier the dossier was
used to get a warrant did he tell the
FISA judge its unverified did he tell
the FISA judge any of this information
no he did not
okay that is guilt by omission purposely
omitting information that likely would
have had a big impact on that
all right player number three tonight
former deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
now the GOP House memo that details how
mccabe testified without the dossier the
FISA warrant to surveil would never have
been approved and McCabe is also tied to
the Clinton email cover-up remember the
recent reports Andrew McCabe he was
forced to resign over revelations and a
soon to be released DOJ Inspector
General report and we're told all about
the Clinton email investigation and The
Wall Street Journal is reporting that
McCabe and other top FBI officials
remember they also knew about Huma
Abaddon's emails that were found on
Anthony Weiner's laptop they knew about
them in September or 2016 important
information but they waited at least a
month before they told Congress and we
can't forget McCabe's wife she got seven
hundred thousand dollars on a
astronomical amount of money for a
failed Senate run in the Commonwealth of
Virginia from a group tied to Clinton
ally Terry McAuliffe and from the
Virginia Democratic Party now McCabe
eventually had to recuse himself from
the can email investigation was because
he got caught or because he thought it
was the right thing to do he got two key
allies of Andrew McCabe now they're
corrupt and they're the Trump bashing
FBI lovers Peter struck and Lisa Paige
now they're players number four and five
Paige actually served as the legal
counsel to McCabe and as for struck like
we've been telling you he's at the
epicenter of the scandal every scandal
every issue that we've been talking
about the last year and a half now
struck as a former top FBI
counterintelligence official he's the
one that signed the documents that
kicked off this phony Russia probe he
also also oversaw the interviews of
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn he was
the guy that interviewed Hillary Clinton
and her top aides and we've already told
you how struck played a key role in
changing the Clinton exoneration
statement remember they were changing
gross negligence extreme carelessness
then there's struck and pages extreme
hatred of Donald Trump
remember in text messages they called
him an idiot a menace a loathsome human
being they said of Trump and of Clinton
wanted to win a hundred million to zero
and struck and Paige also talked with
who we now think is Andrew McCain
about that insurance policy oh god
forbid Donald Trump the Trump wins the
election and yesterday we got a new
batch of text messages that show their
inherent anti-trump bias in the lead up
of course to the election lisa page was
fearful oh my gosh Donald Trump is going
to win on election day struck Reich's
back oh my god this is blanking
terrifying and the following day he says
oh my god I'm so depressed and a couple
of days later Lisa page writes well I
bought all the president's men and I
figure I needed to brush up on Watergate
the insurance people then later paid
Sens of message that reads God being
here makes me angry lots of highfalutin
national security talk and meanwhile we
have our tasks ahead of us wonder if
that's tied to the insurance policy
what does page mean by task when you put
all of this together with the insurance
policy text it raises serious serious
red flags
now these lovebirds also message back
and forth about Special Counsel Robert
Muller remember they had five months of
missing text well right after Robert
Muller was appointed on May 19 two days
after the appointment struck was
debating about joining the investigation
and struck as his lover page an
investigation leading to impeachment so
even before Muller's probe even before
it got started
struck and page we're talking about
impeaching President Trump now this part
is very important during the same
back-and-forth struck text while you and
I both know the odds are nothing if I
thought it was likely I'd be there no
question meeting with Muller I hesitate
in part because of my gut sense and
concern there's no big there they're
pretty stunning admission now struck
helped start the Russia investigation
but he thought there was no there there
also directly wrapped up in all of this
is the demoted DOJ official Bruce oar
and his wife Nellie and their players
six and seven in this game if you want
to call it a game of corruption Bruce or
he was reprimanded at the DOJ after it
was discovered he was meeting with
fusion GPS both before and after the
election and
his office remember just four doors down
from Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein his wife Nellie or she worked
at fusion GPS and by the way her job
focusing in on the anti-trump opposition
research dossier and according to the
new Ness memo Bruce or told
investigators that he had a close
relationship with the dossier author
Christopher Steele and Bruce or said
that Steele said he was desperate that
Donald Trump not get elected and was
passionate about him not being President
pretty amazing
he couldn't write this in a novel now we
turn our attention to the former
attorney general Loretta Lynch she's
player number eight in all of this and
according to testimony from former FBI
director James Comey Lynch instructed
the FBI to refer to their criminal
investigation into Hillary Clinton as
the matter don't call it an
investigation don't call it what it
really is and then it got worse in June
of 2016
while the FBI's so-called independent
investigation is ongoing
Bill Clinton is meeting with Loretta
Lynch in Phoenix on a tarmac for 40
minutes and Lynch said the media was
about grandchildren in golf but this is
on July 1st now the former AG announced
that she was stepping away from the
investigation after this and she just
accept the FBI's conclusion now keep in
mind this all took place before Hillary
Clinton was interviewed on the 4th of
July weekend by the FBI and then
exonerated the next business day and
after Lynch announced that she was
taking a back seat to the Clinton
investigation struck literally text page
and says timing looks like hell pager
replies yet awful timing and then adds
oh it's a real Profile in Courage
talking about Lynch since she knows no
charges will be brought now four days
later Comey holds his press conference
where his infamously announces the FBI
is not recommending charges against
Clinton after 13 and a half minutes of
laying out a pretty damning case against
Tillery the Deputy Attorney General rod
Rosenstein he's also a player in all of
this as ongoing FISA scandal will call
him player number 9 tonight
now first and foremost Rosenstein he
oversees the entire Russian
investigation and he was the official
responsible for appointing Robert Muller
as a special counsel we'll have more
in a minute but first we know that it
was Rosenstein who signed off on one of
the applications to extend the FISA
warrant against the Trump campaign and
then you have President Obama oh yeah
what about him we'll call him player
number 10 tonight if Russia interfering
in our election was so troubling why
didn't the Obama administration say
something prior to the election
we now have an NBC news report the Obama
White House wasn't too worried about it
because quote they thought that Hillary
was going to win well what does that
tell you Hillary wins it's okay
and then the cherry on top is robert
muller will call him player number 11
tonight now the special counsel heading
up the Russia investigation we know that
Muller hired and extremely I mean
extremely partisan team filled with
individuals who had given over 50 grand
but only two Democrats no money to
Donald Trump
we know they gave money don't see Obama
and Clinton and the DNC we also know
Muller is best friends BFF with James
Comey we know that he interviewed with
Trump to be the next FBI director and
the day before he was appointed special
counsel as when that interview took
place so it's all very suspicious and
those are just the main key players in
all of this it gets complicated but I
want to make sure everybody's
understanding this because as we move
forward I would guarantee almost at this
point there's going to be massive
investigations and I would not at all be
surprised people will be going to jail
people will be indicted